jeudi soir là la france entière a revu
la folie des grandeurs et la septième
fois où là où la sixième témoin 7 chez
qu'on a c'est alors que les passages qui
a un peu vieilli mais ya un passage
quand même qui est un grand moment du
cinéma c'est votre strip tease ah oui
mais huit justement c'est une j'ai eu
comme professeur sophie palladium du
crazy du crazy parce que c'était une
très grosse production et gérard oury
m'a dit il faut que tu prennes des
leçons j'ai rencontré sophie c'est une
fille adorable elle m'a dit écoute je
suis très maligne que tu vas t'en sortir
très bien et à ce moment là gérard était
à madrid presque tous les jours son
assistant m'a téléphoné alors tu prends
bien tes cours vous pensez que je
n'allais pas perdre mon temps comme ça
les prend des leçons de lyon de strip
tease oui oui je les je tiens à signaler
que le strip tease c'est moi qui le fais
parce que j'ai été très inspiré ce
jour-là pour tortigue et montcuq et et
ça a été une surprise aussi bien pour
moi que pour vous avez pas profiter du
tout des leçons de ce fier palladium non
il n'y avait pas de leçons vous savez ce
sont des choses qui sont innées
alors quand vous quand vous ne faites
pas du strip tease vous vous écrivez vos
mémoires là vous êtes enfin les cloud -
oui oui oui je sais pas des mémoires
c'est chez mes folies c'est ma vie c'est
tout ce que je vois aussi bien
l'absurdité de la vie la dérision c'est
surtout la dérision qui m'intéresse
beaucoup